am I fat phobic take the quiz I'm
reminded of
I don't
the culture in this country right now
is a series of like odd
quizzes and tests and [__] like
BuzzFeed quizzes like how fat phobic are
you and
if you were a trans superhero which one
would you be
it's it's kind of
it's kind of
like it's it's weirdly like it's
scholarly and yet it's also it's the
antithesis of all things scholarly
you know it's like it's people's in
obsession with grading themselves and
giving themselves grades on how they're
behaving all the time and needing to put
their thoughts and feelings in a box
here's the deal
worry about yourself
worry about the way you want to be
portrayed in the world worry about what
is a realistic way for you to look
try to be better in whatever uh
case that is and try to not pin whatever
your things are on other people
interpersonal fat phobia institutional
fat phobia
I mean it's amazing
there are people that have all kinds of
problems in the world there are drug
addicts there are drunks there are
people that have bad relationships with
food there are people that are just fat
uh because whatever they've been fat a
long time or they have issues or
whatever the case may be and usually
usually if you can treat people kindly
for the most part you don't [__] on
people and you you don't have to
tell someone they're beautiful if you
don't think they're beautiful this is
the thing if you don't think someone's
attractive you don't have to tell them
they're they're attractive
I think part of the problem is that
we're establishing this one-size-fits
all
standard for beauty we are we are we are
trying new Force
the idea
that aesthetic beauty is a political
thing
I think you know what about beauty is in
the eye of the beholder we've kind of
gotten rid of that
because there are people that
certainly
are attractive and overweight there are
people that are skinny and grotesque I
think the ideal is still that you that
bodies that are healthy
and thin
are are are more attractive to people
that is
usually the case and i i people might
get angry at that when I say that but
that is the case you know
people may not like that but that's okay
it doesn't mean that there aren't
attractive fat people it doesn't mean
there aren't gross skinny meth heads it
just means that like
fat phobia isn't real some people are
dicks some people are dicks and you know
they're they're pieces of [__] to people
that are fat or that are whatever and
those people suck but also calling
yourself a warrior because you're fat is
also stupid
that's also pretty dumb
people in this country used to have
personalities
they did I'm old enough to remember
and as those personalities became these
quizzes
people tended now people now just
identify by what grade on the scale they
are uh of of how racist they are or how
fat accepting or how people used to have
personalities distinct interesting
nuanced personalities that came from
different experiences that they didn't
share with everybody but because
Technology's flattened us all and
culture has become this hellish
landscape of constant self-reflection
and mediation on how I should behave and
what should I oh my God am I what scale
am I fat phobic I there was a fat woman
on the plane next to me but I didn't hit
her what does that mean
but then you know I did make a face but
I made it to myself like I don't
I don't I don't even understand here uh
what exactly people are supposed to get
out of this stuff
what are people are supposed to get out
of it but those epic does prove
that everybody kind of wants to lose
weight most people want to lose weight
people are not happy being fat nobody's
really happy there are people that have
that are that are okay with it they go
okay it's like most people are not happy
being drunks either
most people are not really happy being a
drunk it doesn't mean that
most people they seem like they're happy
because you only see the when they're
drunk
but if you see them the next morning or
sometime the next day if you see them
trying to get the keys out of their
pocket to get into a car uh and they're
just like they're not happy
um people they're in the midst of a drug
addiction or not happy so anything that
throws your life out of balance you're
not really happy
there are a lot of people that are
trying to make it in Vogue to be fat or
that it's the uh you know it's but those
epic proves and a lot of things prove
that people would like to to lose weight
if they could this is a fact and the fat
phobia community and the fat activist
Community doesn't want to hear that but
those people have invented jobs for
themselves that's not a job being Fat's
not a job you invented a job I don't get
paid because I'm overweight I get paid
to do this
I mean it's not a job they invented a
job and by the way on on that
I mean to get paid for eating like like
the idea that you're just sitting there
eating and you're like I'm gonna be an
activist and that this Society at this
point is so broken that they fall for it
hey get your bag we'll get a few bags
get the one out of the drive through and
then get the money as well but that's
what we're doing here these are people
that have invented jobs
the person who is riding the fat phobic
quiz should be living in a tent
it's a fact they should be living in a
tent the natural order of things might
be a big tent but they should be living
in a tent they don't it's not a skill
but they've invented a job this is an
economy where we're we're we're
hemorrhaging things for people to do
there's not enough things for people to
do
so the people that just go let me make a
living being aggressively and annoyingly
fat
and let me write quizzes asking people
how comfortable they are with my girth
are getting paid they have a livelihood
that is a livelihood for these people
now
you know
I I just
you know what do you want me to say
about it I'm just like you know
I'd like Meghan Markle better if she was
fat personally like if Prince Harry
married a fat black chick
I would like her more I trust her more
you know
that's just what I'm saying what what
what question on the quiz is that